Encuentra el área de un cuadrado cuyo lado mide 6x menos 5y
¿Ok? Dibujemos por aquí nuestro cuadrado, ahí está nuestro cuadrado y
cada lado del cuadrado, como es un cuadrado todos sus lados miden lo mismo
entonces, cada lado del cuadrado mide
6x menos 5y ok, entonces este lado mide 6x menos 5y
y por lo tanto, este otro lado también mide 6x menos 5y.
Así es que, si queremos calcular el área,
área de este cuadrado, lo que tenemos que hacer es multiplicar base por altura o sea
multiplicar 6x menos 5y por
6x menos 5y y aquí tenemos varias opciones.
Una es seguir lo que nos dice Pau,
nuestra querida amiga Pau y la otra es utilizar la propiedad distributiva,
si te gusta mucho memorizar cosas y hacer las cuentas de una forma mecánica,
entonces puedes usar lo que dice Pau o puedes
simplemente utilizar la propiedad distributiva ¿Ok?
A mí me gusta más utilizar la propiedad distributiva.
Entonces vamos a multiplicar
todo este paréntesis por cada uno de los elementos que se están sumando en este paréntesis.
¿Ok? Entonces nos queda
igual a 6x, 6x por todo nuestro paréntesis
por 6x menos 5y
menos 5y menos
5y por todo nuestro paréntesis o sea por 6x menos
5y y ahora volvemos a aplicar la propiedad distributiva. Vamos a multiplicar
éste por éste, o sea que nos queda 6x por 6x que es 6 por 6
36, 36 "x" por "x",  "x" cuadrada más este 6x por
-5y y entonces lo que nos queda es 6 por -5 eso es -30
y aquí tenemos "x" y "y"
por "x" por "y" y por aquí tenemos que multiplicar -5y
todo esto de aquí, no se nos olvide multiplicar el menos por 6x
y entonces nos queda -5 por 6, eso es -30 y después "x" por "y"
-30 por "x" por "y" y finalmente -5y por -5y.
Ahora aquí tenemos, menos por menos o sea que nos va a quedar un más 5 por 5
25 y "y" por "y", "y" cuadrada
¿Ok? Ya casi terminamos.
Aquí el único detalle que nos falta es que aquí tenemos "x" por "y" y por aquí también tenemos "x" por "y"
entonces podemos sumar estos dos términos y nos queda un solo término -30xy
-30xy eso es igual a -60x por "y"
y nos falta poner por aquí más
25y cuadrada y
36x cuadrada ¿Ok? Estas dos cosas son iguales, y listo ahora sí ya encontramos el área.
Ahora si necesitas hacer esto
rapidísimo pues puedes reconocer que esto de aquí es simplemente un binomio al cuadrado.
Esto de aquí lo puedes escribir como
6x menos 5y
elevado al cuadrado
por que estos 2 son iguales, porque este es un cuadrado y para binomios al cuadrado
tenemos una fórmula directa.
Si tenemos por aquí "a" más "b" al cuadrado, nosotros sabemos que eso es exactamente igual a
"a" más "b" por "a" más "b"
y si hacemos todo este desarrollo que hicimos por aquí pero, con "a" y "b", en lugar de
6x y -5y o cualquier otro valor que queramos sustituir por "a" y por "b"
entonces lo que hacemos es aplicar la propiedad distributiva 2 veces y esto es igual a
tomamos esta "a" y lo multiplicamos por todo este paréntesis
entonces, nos queda "a" por "a" más "b"
y a eso le tenemos que sumar
esta "b" por
todo este paréntesis "a" más "b". Y ahora
volvemos a aplicar la propiedad distributiva en estos dos paréntesis y nos queda
"a" por "a" es una "a" cuadrada
más "a" por "b"
"a" por "b"
más "b" por "a", que en realidad "b" por "a" es lo mismo que "a" por "b",
"a" por "b" más "b" por "b" que es "b" cuadrada ¿Qué hay entonces? Tenemos estos 2
términos que se pueden sumar y nos queda que "a" por "b" más "a" por "b", simplemente 2 por "a"
por "b" y aquí simplemente bajamos estos términos,
más "a" cuadrada ¿Ok? Esta es una forma de encontrar
esta fórmula del binomio al cuadrado.
Otra forma un poquito más directa podría haber sido decir que tenemos que multiplicar
cada uno de los términos de aquí, por
cada uno de los términos de aquí, entonces toca "a" por "a" que es nuestra "a" cuadrada
más "a" por "b" que es una de las "a" por "b" más
"b" por "a" que es lo mismo que  "a" por "b",  entonces ya tenemos 2 de esas "a" por "b"
más "b" por "b" que es "b" cuadrada.
¿Ok? Pero bueno el chiste es que si ya sabemos que si tenemos un binomio
y lo elevamos al cuadrado, nos queda
esta cosa de aquí
entonces podemos simplemente sustituir 6x igual a "a"
y 5x igual a "b" y entonces lo que nos queda es que tenemos por aquí
6x menos 5y elevados al cuadrado
y entonces sabemos que esto es igual a "a" cuadrada más 2
ab más "b" cuadrada y el "a" cuadrado este es él "a" entonces,  6x al cuadrado
6x al cuadrado más
2 veces "a" por "b"
6x menos 5y que es nuestra "b"  más
"b" cuadrada que es -5y al cuadrado -5y
al cuadrado ¿Ok? Entonces haciendo estas cuentas, tenemos que
6 por "x" al cuadrado entonces, 6 al cuadrado es 36
"x" al cuadrado, "x" al cuadrado más 2 por 6 por -5 entonces en realidad es un
menos 2 por -5 es -10 por 6
-60x por "y", xy y finalmente más
-5y al cuadrado ¿Ok? -5 por -5 eso es 25
y "y" al cuadrado
entonces ya tenemos que nos quedó
exactamente la misma cosa, como tenía que quedarnos,
y bueno, en este video vimos muchas formas de desarrollar
binomios al cuadrado. El chiste es que si encontraste este patrón desde el principio
y esta fórmula te parece muy natural
no tienes que hacer todo esto de usar la propiedad
distributiva dos veces. Puedes simplemente usar la fórmula y sustituir los valores de "a" y de "b".
Claro que si lo haces de esta forma, también está muy bien y
seguro no te equivocas,
a menos de que te equivoques en las cuentas
pero espero que no.